This gigantic bat was.
Captured on camera by a man filming his camping trip.
He's been missing ever since.
Stories like these have been swirling the internet for the past couple of years,
with people using pictures and videos to supposedly prove that
human sized bats exist,
but could bats really get that big?
How dangerous would they be?
And why could we make lots of money off their
giant bat poop? This is what if,
and here's what would happen if bats were the size of humans,
bats a whole ready creep a lot of people out.
So imagine how scared people would be if there were giant ones
roaming around and keep in mind that bats usually live
together in groups of 100 to several thousand.
So if you run into one of these giant beasts, chances are,
there'd be a whole army of them nearby.
Would their natural ecosystems be able to sustain these oversized
bats?
To understand what a world with giant bats would be like?
Let's get to know our regular sized bats first,
because there are so many different bat species today.
We're just going to focus on to the flying Fox and the
vampire bat,
vampire bats have a wingspan of 35 to 40
centimeters.
They can run speeds of up to 1.2 meters per second,
and they really like to drink blood.
They drink so much of it that they can double their weight in just one
feeding.
So can you imagine how bloodthirsty they'd be if they were the size of
humans?
Luckily for us bats don't get any bigger than our next
featured player. The flying Fox,
there are 60 flying Fox species and the largest one has a
wingspan of 1.7 meters.
That might sound like it's getting almost human sized,
but the body is pretty smart. About 37 meters in length.
They have a surprisingly big brain for such a small body,
and they're said to be as intelligent as dogs.
So what would life be like if there were millions of human
sized, intelligent blood sucking bats roaming around? Well,
let's find.
Out.
Flying Fox bats would need to be six times bigger to become the size of a
human.
There are new head to toe length would be 170 centimeters.
Their new wingspan would be 10 meters and their
new weight would be 216 kilograms.
They would need to eat about 19 kilograms of fruit every
day, just to sustain themselves with this new hunger,
they would easily wipe out farms and orchards and they disrupt the
entire food chain.
And then there's the vampire bat. Don't worry.
They won't add any more stress to our fruit farms because they're only hungry
for blood. Oh, wait. That sounds even worse.
Human sized vampire bats would be about 170 centimeters long.
They'd have a wingspan of 6.8 meters and a mask of
295 kilograms because of their size.
They would be able to drink 34 liters of blood per meal.
If we want to save our necks,
we might need to raise livestock to offer up to the vampire bats.
We just wouldn't be able to use them for food after,
because the vampire bats would probably infect that livestock
with rabies.
And we wouldn't only have to worry about feeding these big beasts.
We'd also have to worry about where they're going to live.
Usually that's live in groups of a few hundred to a few thousand in
caves, hollow trees, addicts, and barns,
clearly human sized bats.
Wouldn't all fit into the same amount of space anymore.
They might need to create smaller groups, take over buildings and parks,
their sheer size food requirements and bodily functions could
damage their new homes. But on the bright side,
their bodily functions could also make you rich.
That excrement also known as guano is an effective fertilizer.
It has high amounts of nitrogen, phosphate, and potassium,
and it can be very expensive right now.
An average bat only releases about two and a half grams of guano each
year. But with these new human sized bats,
eating upwards of 19 kilograms every day,
their guano production will increase dramatically.
So if you're brave enough to get near these beastly creatures to
collect their poop, you could make a lot of money.
All you'd have to do next is figure out how to spend it,
but that's a story for another, whatever.